oh you got it all the way yeah
good job get out of the studio this is
blasphemy jack boys you go
[Music]
welcome to Sims and left go everybody
we're not in the studio and we're
dressed like hey what up al good to see
you and this who is this jolly old Saint
Nick show who you are big reveal we're
back with the main man himself Sam darn
old and we're here at the Livingston
mall today it's not Santa Claus
that's what I'm looking at it's Santa
Claus
[Music]
oh ho
Oh Vanna we got Joey here Oh buddy Oh
tell me what you want for Christmas this
year oh that's a great game I've heard
from all the kids what do you guys want
for Christmas this year
a puppy surprise and you're a Nerf ball
a nerf gun we definitely have a lot we
are a lot of those we do Santa we got
Steven here Oh Oh Steven what do you
want for Christmas this year
se Kwang Barkley Jersey what do you want
for Christmas this year
say Kwan do you watch football who's
your favorite team hey buddy what's your
name Blake good to meet you oh I like it
right here I like oh yeah that's a
really cool Jersey you got on there
who's your favorite player on the Jets
Lord Jamal I think maybe one day you'll
be able to meet one of those guys maybe
next year though he's your cousin that's
cool good family cool his name we've had
yet Santa what is it Chris I like that
name kind of what do you want for
Christmas is to your buddy a skateboard
do you like the Jets yeah so Santa used
to play football at North Pole high
school and we want him to throw you a
pass a little bit further than that
off target yeah yeah you had to go up
and get that one didn't you we were
wondering if anyone wanted to catch
passes from Santa Claus see what you got
Santa
[Music]
Oh Santa can really throw you got it all
the way yeah good job
the reindeer told me that it's time for
you to go to the bathroom it's a girl
yes it is I know Santa's got to go to
the bathroom Santa can't hold it in I
[Music]
don't know what happened to Santa but
his friend came and I want you to meet
him okay I want to introduce you to the
starting quarterback of the New York
Jets
oh thank you so much
[Applause]
Santa Claus Santa Claus you enjoy being
an elf I did I really have yeah it was
good you were cute little elf though
real cute
thank ya way to help out Santa you know
I appreciate that I'm gonna take that
compliment and not even go back to you
yeah one person that doesn't like
Christmas Bill Belichick hmm came out
and said I dare you say that they had
Christmas comes in an inconvenient time
right in the middle of football season
which is Bill Belichick to a tee right
in fact if he said he liked Christmas I
would have been disappointed well he's
he's a curmudgeon we mean I could just
see him like pretending to open up gifts
and going this is great but like
actually having play halls this is all
just getting in the way right now okay
he's trying to get ready for the
playoffs and he doesn't want to worry
about who's naughty and who's nice Bill
Belichick likes New Year's uh well it I
don't think he cares
because as my New England friends always
joke when the playoffs start they always
go regular season starting for us which
is pretty true so jealous so that's an
inconvenient time for Bill Belichick but
I want to talk about inconvenient truths
[Music]
I'm gonna give the team you tell me the
inconvenient truth about this playoff
team and what could hold them back
gotcha the New Orleans Saints the New
Orleans Saints I'll tell you one of the
incan what they've been leading on well
I will say this I think one of the
inconvenient truths and it's been
exposed a little bit is Drew Brees and
what he can bring to the Saints offense
I know we're gonna open up a can of
worms here what do you want but we don't
mention offenses all the time right how
great offenses make you defend the whole
soil but he's not at this age 39 years
old he's not capable of scrambling out
of the pocket making plays that way
money against Carolina when the rush got
there the play was over right exactly
right he's not gonna make any physically
demanding plays that we're gonna go whoa
there was nobody open the protection
wasn't that great and he still made it
happen and hey listen he throws the ball
shorter downfield he's tied with Eli
Manning for 28th and football yards and
attended area ARDS yeah him and Eli tied
yes so again they can win the Super Bowl
with him yeah but there is little issues
with his game and when you see teams
take away their screens and things like
that that offense doesn't work as
smoothly because
nobody's scared of drew brees throwing
bombs over their head there's one team
that everybody is piling on right now
yeah because they're excited they no
longer have a buy right hey treants ooh
I'm still scared of the picture yes I
you should put that out right but what
is there inconvenient truth there
inconvenient truth is that Gronk is no
longer the greatest mismatch in football
that has n Gronk is no longer holding
the trophy as the best tight end in the
game and I would even argue that he's
not even Brady's go-to guy all the time
I think there's been big moments during
the year where he's gone I'm gonna go to
Josh Gordon here I trust him in this
situation
and since Josh Gordon's been there he's
been targeted more than any other
receiver on their team I want a real yes
Gronk Oh Gronk has lost a step yeah I do
think he's lost his intensity yeah and I
don't think hey there's a reason New
England was rumored to be trying to
trade him in the offseason
I think they saw a few you know dents in
the armor here that were about to come
about few more dents in the armor yeah
LA Rams right offense has been
struggling yeah it's the inconvenient
truth about the rim
people are gonna point to Jared Goff
right they are who's been in struggles
Ville I mean such nonetheless it's not
perfect okay I get that so he deserves
some of the blade but the real
inconvenient truth is the interior part
of their offensive line they got big
time issues there and that's really the
biggest reason you've seen all three of
their losses
Sheldon Rankin's whooped them for the
Saints okay Eddie Goldman and Hakeem
Hicks whooped them when they dominate
them right Fletcher Cox and your ego
look there but this paddle we how that
happen that's the Inconvenient Truth
now they can't win any of those battles
on the inside the running games not
working and of course pressures getting
into golf space and he's not a sharp
either I have one more in giving one for
it and it's me to you oh gosh and I'm a
little convenient that I got to work
with you on a daily basis all right well
now I'm not afraid to say that no I
can't believe I'm saying this what he's
over my shoulder yeah I don't think
Aaron Rogers the best quarterback in the
NFL anymore well you sound like my son
Phillip who laughs last week was
watching Patrick mahomes on Thursday
night and said my home is better than
rounders now yeah look I'm just happy
that one Sims in the family has some
sense but I think that Patrick mahomes
is far and away get out of this get out
of this
this is blasphemy the second shrine in
here blasphemy where is Adam left go who
what where did my host go I'm just
saying he doesn't have tyree kill he
didn't have Kareem hunt he doesn't have
Andy Reid he doesn't have Sammy Watkins
he doesn't have Travis Kelce Aaron
Rodgers you're still the greatest but
even the greatest needs help some I am
not saying he's worse than - yeah I'm
just saying he's not what it's the first
year I'm not gonna lie I've had moments
I know I've had moments where I've gone
huh this is getting closer I said huh
this is getting kind of close Wow but
I'm still not gonna give him the numbers
part that it was fill up is I can keep
Sims and left go and just replace you
with him I love that thanks a lot me
next week
Hale Chris Dawson aka CJ - cake and you
watching films and left go somebody left
cup one second one second I just want to
make sure Ally's not here to surprise me
not today because I found him back where
he should be in his newspaper stand
picking winners enough losers Ali get
back on track
Chiefs Chargers I'm at home and I'm
going another win by Ali instead of
seven and two year now six and three
because of Phillip Rivers what does that
do to your heart to know that you took
an L on the hands of Phil out last week
I think it hurts me more des he could
have been a giant go back to the
Chargers for this week
okay Ravens at chargers Chargers favored
by four and a half Lamar Jackson still
go in there fighting for that six seed
then you got the Chargers they should
have Melvin Gordon back we don't know
about Keenan Allen but they're fighting
for the one seat and for the one and
Philip Rivers would rather be in the
first sea yes in a second they're at
home four and a half four and a half
four and a half so ones down chargers
mmm I'm going with the charges I think
I'm going with the home-field advantage
just about every week are you just
realizing this I think so
and I like the charges at home I do I
don't think that all Ravens are going to
travel and go into LA and beat the
charges no Phillip Rivers not having
that do you see how he went from kind of
sure to be like absolutely not I had to
talk myself into it yeah Ali is taking
the Chargers - four and a half at home
against the rave he's crazy he's
absolutely crazy Lobby we're gonna say
you're crazy well they're already saying
but you're really hot and heavy on
Baltimore right now well IIM how against
the charge I am hot and heavy I think
it's a matchup sport you and I talk
about that all the time right every team
has their kryptonite I do think that the
Baltimore Ravens are kind of the Los
Angeles chargers kryptonite the big
thing is and this is where I really
worry about the Chargers you've heard me
talk about their than one of the
smallest defenses in football right and
they're in their nose tackle Damien
Square is 290 something pounds that's
not big in the NFL world and especially
not against the Baltimore Ravens who are
333 15 305 320 and then 340 and then
they are obsessed with running the ball
down hill with a Gus Edwards who's a big
back so that's where they can impose
their will they can control
the clock and then the Lamar Jackson
element off of it to where you start
worrying about damn they're smashing us
in between the tackles and then he keeps
it off edge yeah so they're a very tough
team
I think matchup lies uh you know that
I've read or died with the Eagles my
entire life yes right and there is a
thing going on right now whether it's
Malcolm Jenkins on the bench we're in a
scheme a store Rodney McCloud leading
out the team with ski masks yeah last
year it was the underdog mask yeah
because they said we were an underdog
right now they're the jack boys yeah
which means we're stealing stuff oh I
think you're gonna win we're robbing you
and they're all wearing ski right up
Culley style and I have I would award
the dog last year yeah I'm not wearing
this that here's my question for you yes
there's two games left right one against
the Texans then then the year with
Washington they need other teams to lose
right should I emotionally get into this
or is it best if I just go the Eagles it
was a good run no get into it I think
it's time go ahead
I mean you're playing two teams that you
match up well with at the end of it
anymore
give me more right so I mean it why any
more confidence I don't have a lot of
confidence to you like I said last year
I would have put on the dog man I do
Nick Foles is back oh my gosh you know
what's amazing
right is that Carson Wentz is gonna be
traded for a first-round pick and we're
gonna Nick Foles and I can't see in this
that's it how do I look Simms it's all
about the quarterback Jack boys it's
actually an improvement I think you
should wear this every week for Sims
peace out homies on the lef koe robber
man and we will holla at you later
[Music]
Santa nice meeting you yeah be good man
all right yeah good good luck with
everybody thank you
Sana's a hell of a guy as usual making
us look bad
hey what's up homies thanks for watching
subscribe to the BR YouTube channel man
you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot other videos
check them out and then what time does
our show come out Wednesday 8 p.m. be
there or be square
he ruined it it was really close